la coordination nationale des
infirmières ayant adopté une motion
demandant une entrevue avec le président
de la république l'elysée a fait savoir
que le chef de l'état faisait entière
confiance au gouvernement pour mener le
dialogue social et que donc aucune
audience n'était prévue pour le moment
ce thème de la nécessité du dialogue
social le président de la république a
eu l'occasion de le développer également
au cours de son déplacement dans le
département du rhône où il a trouvé sur
son chemin
cheminots et infirmières mécontents
michel vient malgré sa brièveté
l'itinéraire lyonnais de françois
mitterrand aujourd'hui n'aura donc pas
manquer à l'air du temps celui de la
crau l'indication sociale dès son
arrivée ce matin à oullins le chef de
l'état a été accueilli par quelques
dizaines de cheminots menacés par la
fermeture de l'atelier local de la sncf
des cheminots relayé quelques minutes
plus tard à villeurbanne par une
centaine d'infirmières venus manifester
leur mécontentement lors de
l'inauguration de la maison du livre de
l'image et du son
mais s'il prônait la sab le mans le
dialogue social et s'il accepte
d'entendre les récriminations le
président de la république estime en
revanche que le rôle du gouvernement est
de les écouter
j'entends - d'éloges que des critiques
et c'est bien normal je suis là pour ça
il faut bien que j'entende la plate des
français quand ça va pas et là où ça va
pas les problèmes nationaux se retrouve
partout tout cela doit être entendu tout
cela doit être discuté
libéré de la gestion quotidienne des
affaires dont ils souhaitent confier
l'entière responsabilité au gouvernement
de michel rocard une confiance
d'ailleurs renouvelé dans un communiqué
publié cet après-midi par l'elysée
françois mitterrand entend promouvoir de
grands desseins ainsi ce matin la
transformation de la ville et des
banlieues après avoir visité la première
tranche du projet de réhabilitation du
centre doullens un projet signé roland
castro quant à la rencontre avec raymond
barre élus du rhône après le baptême de
la promotion du centenaire de l'école du
service de santé des armées de bron elle
n'a donné lieu qu'à une poignée de main
et un sourire mais le dialogue avait
peut-être déjà commencé ailleurs